yeah you knew I was doing it you know I
had to do a spoiler discussion on apes
on horses straw so when dawn of the
Planet of the Apes there's a lot of cool
[ __ ] to talk about yeah as you know I
don't do a spoiler video for everything
example Tammy didn't give a [ __ ] - but
Apes yeah let's do that
cuz that [ __ ] is red at the beginning of
dawn of the Planet of the Apes you see
Caesar and his civilization you're like
alright they're flourishing they haven't
seen humans in a couple years life is
good for them then agent friendzone from
fringe comes along a couple he gets
freaked out he wastes one that's when
that scene in the trailer comes where
all these Apes are just in the trees and
the main dudes like we don't mean you
any harm and friendzone from fringe is
like they're just Apes man he's like do
they look like just Apes to you you look
around you're like yeah that's a nice
solid military formation they got going
on I'd listen to him what I love is
alright at this point we know Caesar
talks we saw it happen in the last movie
yeah that one scene that you YouTube
very often and you watch because it's
just one of the coolest moments in
movies ever is look at Amy's all go and
you feel like you heard him talk for the
very first time even they're freaked out
that's what I love about this movie is
even though you know Caesar talks every
time Caesar talks people are so shocked
that it happens you feel like you're
watching it happen for the first time
you're like oh that is so he's so cool
he's so he's still the John Connor of
apes and at the point when the main
human was like we need the dam to get
power I was like alright this is going
to be avatar main humans gonna be
hanging out with the Apes the dam is
gonna be the unobtanium that the humans
want then general dick porridge who will
call Gary Oldman this time around is
gonna be like ah but we need it he's
gonna go to war with the Apes and the
main dudes gonna fight alongside the
Apes against the humans hey guess what
didn't happen any of that [ __ ] like I
said in my spoiler free review the thing
you got to keep your eye on in this
movie is koba koba new from the last
movie this guy was gonna be a bad egg
from the start but he just didn't know
how much he put a gun in caesar's kid's
hand and had him fight for a Cause his
father was adamantly against that his
dick have you no shame
until this point the apes and caesar
they've been like ah humans have
destroyed themselves their dicks we are
better than that usually how things like
this are the very black and wise like
humans killed themselves often now
there's us we have a pristine
civilization but would it be like that
probably not they have very human traits
like ambition and anger and [ __ ] like
that so at that point how far does it go
well Koba shows us it goes to here
aggression deceit framing
human beings have a strict rule though
like Apes don't kill Apes like Koba
assesses well it's not really killing
it's not murder if you frame humans and
go to war that needs to happen so we
maintain domina its its murder but he
goes that extra mile he shoots Caesar
Caesar sees it happen as the worst I've
seen or just got shot and in fell he
didn't know who did it alright Caesar
would probably be like why did it
hindman being shoot me that's the point
is he sees Koba look some right in the
eyes when it happened the co bizarre
grinning that really gross scarred up a
screen and then Caesar just falls over
and dies I really thought Caesar was
dead I'm not gonna lie to you usually
I'm that guy who can be like oh they
didn't show that scene in the movie that
they showed in the trailer so Caesars
alive which I did think about but I was
like oh they didn't show that scene in
the trailer where Caesars watching the
camcorder and he's watching all the 127
hours but it but I thought maybe that
was a scene that they deleted out of the
movie because it felt too shoehorned
into the movies alright deleted scene
Caesars dead so Koba frames people that
one egg just looks to the humans he's
like run yep that's what I was thinking
that's what the ape was thinking that's
what the humans were thinking that's
what the humans did they get the [ __ ]
out of Dodge I go they hide the Apes go
to war with humans at this point the
Apes go and ransack the human city now I
thought gary oldman like I said was
gonna be the dick in the movie he really
wasn't in fact
I really empathize with Gary Oldman a
lot he's lost his family I see where he
gets his iPod back running and he said
crying cuz you seen pictures of his
family for the first time in God knows
how long
holy [ __ ] who didn't choke up on that
Koba leads the assault the apes are
divided the like I don't think Cesar's
want us to do this Koba goes and grabs
that one he could just beat him to death
like an ape and that would be that but
no he needs to freak him out and make an
example he takes him over to that
precipice and just throws him over you
are becoming what you hate Koba and
that's another thing I loved about this
movie - Caesars talking to his son he
was like I just thought humans were
dicks I didn't realize how like them we
are so easy to be like all humans are
douches and apes take over and they're
intelligent they're the good guys what
would it be like that if an animal
really gained the intelligence of a
human being I feel like they'd have the
same problems we have like murder and
war and anger and prejudice even at the
end of the movie when the main dudes
like it Gary Oldman stop don't blow the
c4 don't blow the tower
seizures after he's gonna regain control
of the Apes all will be right with the
world Gary Oldman's like sorry I'm
saving the human race BAM even at that
when I was like I don't think Gary
Oldman's a dick really put yourself in
the guys shoes these apes have all just
swarmed your human city the last human
city as far as you know but you know
there are others because now the
military's common point is he feels it's
his responsibility to keep these people
safe he's probably like I'm sorry I
don't think you're wounded ape is gonna
win a fight against Scarface up there I
can't say I wouldn't have blown the
tower if I was Gary Oldman myself when
he blow up the tower and blew himself up
I was like you gotta do what you got to
do man doesn't change the fact Caesar
regains control of the pack when he has
Koba by the arm and Kobe's like a
no-kill ape he's like no doesn't apply
to you he drops his ass he doesn't just
drop him he hits a chord and then hits
that big crane thing it all folds in on
itself onto him and then it drops I love
it when leaders with such a staunch rule
you know they're like oh we don't break
this rule have to break the rule like
when Batman had to push to face over the
ledge in the Dark Knight and kill him
but what was the alternative he had no
alternative it's just the same thing at
that point the dudes like the military's
coming where the war is coming is like
Wars already begun it's just gonna suck
ass but God willing this movie makes its
money back we'll see each other in the
third one you know what I love about
these Apes movies is I don't know when
the next one will take place is going to
take place like a year after this two
months after this an eon after this are
we gonna see you know Cornelius and the
Apes who talk and [ __ ] yeah they talk in
this movie but they don't like talk talk
there are a few years away from being
like space bald [ __ ] [ __ ] the planet
I love that I love not knowing where the
sequel is gonna take us but you know
there's gonna be a singer there has to
be a sequel don't reboot this [ __ ] now
let me carry it through to the end
watch it ties into the Mark Wahlberg one
mm-hmm point is I loved this movie I
loved where it took us I loved Koba I
loved Caesar Caesar still the biggest
awesome Jesus a badass John Connor
character that could have been in this
movie I can't wait to see where the cig
will go so dawn of the Planet of the
Apes what was your favorite part of it
whatever it was comment below let me
know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you